shows also brought to you by anna.com go
to honor.com and use cardboard Church to
save 10 on all their amazing
optimization products like Alpha Brain
New Moon stream tech Community stream
tech support
[Music]
kick it Lee
Monday August 8th
oh [__]
it's the church
[Music]
oh [__]
tremendous
we're here
we're ready to go
we're tuned up
police syed's here
Eureka Vape is coming
and that's all that [__] matters it's
a church of what's happened now [__]
what's up dog
I'm doing great looking good oh yeah
nice weekend you had your blue apron
yeah man yeah nice
you miss Paula yeah I I mean where is
she now right now she's in Paris which
is terrifying and when does she come
home Sunday all right so you got five
more days to sweat it out bang couple
out oh yeah don't worry about that
[__] desires I had a great time at
the Cherokee Casino oh yeah I want to
thank all the people that came out some
Savage gave me a bong another dude gave
me a [__] cigar which I thought was a
cigar I got up to my [__] room I
looked at I go assistant God I'm happy
I'm gonna bring it back give it to the
[__] spirits on Monday Sunday I get
home I open up the [__] cigar and
there's a note in there and they carved
out a joint into the [__] thing and
there was two hits of acid in the
[__] lid you understand me this is
why I love the [__] these last
[__] uh
you know these towns Buffalo Oklahoma
all these towns these are the last
[__] frontiers of civilization the
rest of you [__] are start
bucking it up and you're missing the
beauty of what these [__] got
to offer I didn't bring the cigar down
with me he wrote his hotel room on there
and I tell you what man
we had to be up at five because the car
was picking us up at 5 45.
so if you're listening my deepest
apologies you told me the room number
407 but and then I saw it again on the
note and I was like [__] I went back to
the room sometimes I get insomnia and I
walk around I go get chips or [__]
soda listen I went up to my room I
[__] only I I was back there I
haven't turned the TV on when I leave
for the show I'm already [__] packed
and the close of the morning already out
so when I get up in the morning all I
gotta do is take a shower wash my little
monkey and bang put my clothes on I'm
bing bang badoop I'm ready to [__] go
but the Indian casino was great nice
people the people ran it were very nice
I didn't see a lot of Indians except the
people who worked there
yeah you were saying uh it was very
interesting just like talking to them
and learning about their culture yeah no
it was real interesting I started
looking at the art and stuff and I
started getting emotional you know it's
just great stuff to be around and to see
from time to time the people who came to
the show were [__] great they drove
from Tulsa Wichita places like that I
want to thank all of you guys
it's a long [__] drive we had a good
time some lady ran out she thought Jim
Gaffigan was there well Joey was there
slinging dick and giving out bubble gums
while I was on stage by mistake I said
you know you guys are The Last of the
Mohicans I forgot I was in the Cherokee
Casino it's [__] crazy I'm half
[__] but that's what happens when
your grandmother and your grandfather's
second cousins you know what I'm saying
there's got to be a [__] somewhere in
the [__] family on paper I'm not
really [__] but like if you see me
like he's not all chinked up but
yeah I am I am [__] up in real life
but anyway
uh what else [__] happened this
weekend Lee what else happened oh I
don't want to talk about it okay a lot
of [__] people
it's amazing what people on social media
react though
it really is amazing
Friday morning I gotta flight at 6 30 at
night
I gotta kill all of Friday you know what
I worked out twice I did kettlebells
twice I did two Mobility classes I went
to the Y one day last week and just hit
the bag to sweat I was a little slow on
[__] Friday right I wake up I go you
know what my wife's going to yoga right
I listened to the recording they gave me
the flappers recording I was making
notes on that by 11 o'clock you know
what man what the [__] am I gonna do
here
I don't have to leave here till 3 30.
that my wife doesn't get back till 12
30. what the [__] am I gonna do here
I don't know what I paid for the Jujitsu
let me [__] go down there I got my
ghee on I go down there
I do the class towards the end of the
class he takes me out of the uh
fundamentals class [__] I want you to
spar in here today
and it makes me small with the chick two
[__] fights with her she twist up my
arm
then after class I'm standing and he
goes we got some promotions today so I
thought I was getting a strike
I didn't no no I didn't see any stripes
on his jeans
so I didn't really say nothing
I said ain't gonna be me which I didn't
give a [__] you know I just go to
Jujitsu dog and also he goes Joey come
on up here I'm giving you a blue about
my [__] heart stopped me
my one knee went out for Monday I
couldn't [__] believe it
you know and I'm not a [__] blue belt
by no means am I a blue belt I just go
I just go and I'm a little old and I
move a little slower but I'm [__]
trying you know what I'm saying well
it's different because we were I think
maybe maybe we you and I were talking
about it separately but I thought you
going to karate and then like how you
how there were belts for karate
but the belt like that there's like a a
form and maybe you have to know certain
things for jiu jitsu isn't it more just
like where your instructor thinks you
are yeah what he thinks you're at so
it's kind of weird I'm [__] terrible
so I didn't you know and I'm moving a
little better I'm doing some moves a
little better I'm sweeping people
you know I just don't lay there anymore
at least I got a little love on the
bottom now I get you in a deep half and
[__] like that
but it's so weird how I got a lot of
emails on Facebook and on Gmail and
people were really surprised and it's uh
quitting when you do something and you
don't like it listen I went to Plumbing
School
one day I'm like
these are clean pipes I'm gonna have to
be doing this with real life [__] I
don't want to do this I didn't do it I
quit you know when I was electrician I
did it when I realized it wasn't the pay
I wanted I [__] quit
there's nothing wrong with quitting
something if you don't really like it
but you shouldn't quit something because
you you're bad at it you know what
you're good at you know what you're bad
at in life listen if you made me fix my
car right now I just shoot myself I
could change oil I could change a flat
the whole time that's more than I can do
the whole time I'm doing it I'm scared
shitless
when I change the flag I change oil the
whole time I'm thinking the car is going
to blow up or something like that you
know when I when I went on the road when
you go on the road with a car that's not
a brand new car you learn a lot about
tricks tape
[__] uh the [__] to seal your
radiator
you just learn so I learned things from
different people you know I learned how
to [__] change the flat you know you
can either pay 18 bucks you could pay
three dollars for the thing of oil and
put it in there yourself and you know
see where the measuring stick is you
know I mean you learn to do all these
things but I have no aptitude for that I
have no aptitude to take apart a
computer and put it back together my
wife could do it you give her a [__]
week with anything an oven
anything she'll put it back [__]
together I don't have that [__]
amplitude
I have aptitude when it comes to talking
to people and selling [__] and doing
mischievous [__] things you know what
I'm saying but
uh I never liked wrestling
I just can't it just came during
football season and basketball season so
it was kind of weird for me you know
what I'm saying it was like a pickle all
of them I never knew existed when I was
a kid and I mean the wrestling existed
until I moved to North Bergen
you know I never [__] know and by
that time basketball was one basketball
was more important so I never knew
nothing about it so when these guys are
talking about jujitsu I would just play
it off like I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about
but I started just watching it alone
without the UFC like just watching a jiu
jitsu match and I was blown away and I
knew I wanted to at least try it you
know what I'm saying
and it's been rough but
it was better than the alternative
what do you think the alternative was
the alternative was what happened to me
in 1979.
that's my alternative when it comes to
that [__]
you know
I got into karate in like 1970.
as a child and
I wasn't great at it you know God knows
I wasn't good at it
but after about two years I got really
good at it I always had good flexibility
and I could jump high
so my kicks were good my balance was
good my punches I don't know if they
were strong or not but I had I could do
forms and I wasn't bad
you know one minute remember one minute
you're at the end of the class you know
like when you get to jiu jitsu and
you're the lowest Wipeout
but if you stick with it for a while
next thing you know you're in the middle
of the line
you're in the middle of the line but I
think at least would mess with me a
little bit is like yeah you might be in
the middle of the line but you know like
already some of the other kids are
better like not kids but other people
are better than you and that was
I feel like ego comes comes into it a
lot because
you were just talking about how like
we're all good at different things so
sometimes I'm thinking okay I shouldn't
try to be good at something I'm not good
at
just because like why why try to force
it but then with Jiu Jitsu you said it
wasn't in your wheelhouse but you stuck
you stick with it like how do you know
when to stick with something and when to
like jettison it well because of the
mistake I made I made two mistakes
before I was 20.
I quit two things that I [__] loved
for no reason for drugs and stupidity
and just I don't know why I quit karate
in 79. I still beat myself up do you
want me to tell you why I just had too
much [__] on my plate and karate was too
[__] far away
it was it was like going to Higgins for
me that's what and I had to do it by bus
so it was my whole [__] night right
yeah you know and I had the stamina like
I would go to school and go to
basketball practice and then shoot the
karate go home eat and then take the bus
to karate and catch the [__] Adult
class
when would you do homework when I get
back from karate at 9 30 or I do
homework during the day during little
periods or lunch
like I was really good at I've always
been really good at organizing time to
do [__]
well yeah you can organize time but I I
think you're gonna run into it soon
that's what it was see that's what it
was it was it wasn't kids it was that at
that time I was playing basketball
you know helping my mom at the bar
trying to have a social life in North
Bergen
and at the same time three nights a week
I'm in Union City doing [__] karate
and I'm [__] 13 years old 14 15 16
and I did this I did this all through
from the age of 11.
to 16. I stuck it out with the same
karate teacher in Union City
I went from one belt to maybe four belts
later with it when I got there I was a
certain belt but he made me start over
and I stuck it out but because I quit
that I quit High School
I quit that I quit high school but the
thing I loved the most was basketball
again
another thing I saw myself as a complete
[__]
idiot
but I wanted it so bad
that I practice morning noon and night I
played morning noon and night I seeked
out the best competition to play morning
noon and night
and I started and then I went to
freshman year and I didn't start and
again ego came into [__] situation
in that situation ego came into
situation when I quit High School
necessity
any necessity made me quit situation but
what I needed was a good or bad that's
the question there
what made me quit karate
to be honest yeah I wanted a party
those kids didn't [__] party how old
were you though when I quit karate
15. Jesus that's that's I I hadn't even
thought about partying in 15. like
that's that's the thing that I think is
so for two years I partied a long but
very secretly
a couple of joints a beer
you know nothing hard nothing
and by the time uh yeah I think I did
THC or something or masculine and then I
went to karate for a few months
and then I just knew I outgrew the Hang
section of it like those kids weren't
uh interesting to me anymore like I
wanted to be around women
I wanted a [__] smoke pot I wanted to
walk around that night so I wanted that
[__] in my life instead of what the
karate people had to offer which is
health
Focus
you know camaraderie and no drugs
and it was too much for you as a kid it
was too much so now I go 30 years later
I remember when I got into comedy
but when I got into comedy it took me
about a year to commit
and then I went to New York and I never
forget on the on the drive here with
that girl
I thought to myself
I've been doing I've been I've been
[__] around with this for two years
I've been [__] around with comedy for
two years
selling drugs doing blow canceling spots
yeah I do a weekend here and do okay you
know [__] like that
if I do this complete move I'm doing
it's because I'm going to give my life
to Comedy
that's the only way I'm gonna do comedy
and I [__] stuck with it late I don't
know Lee if you knew me at that time
when I made that decision I just said
I'm doing it I'm [__] doing it every
night twice a night if I have to three
times if I can
I'm just gonna keep doing it and doing
it and doing it and doing it I just made
my decision sometimes in December
you know I was at vmac we weren't steady
he went away for a week
that whole week had me all [__] up and
like I said I went to Flappers I saw the
Alberto I went over there I tried two
classes I said I want to sign up and I
uh before I gave the money I said if I
do this
it's because I'm gonna go every Monday
and Wednesday
that's it there's no other that's on the
schedule when I make my schedule for the
week Monday and Wednesday is always 12
o'clock BJJ if you got something an
envelope or a significant meeting I will
cancel that and try to make it on
Tuesday
I don't have acupuncture no more on
you know she went back to Marina del Rey
if you think I'm going to [__] Marina
Del Rey on a Tuesday you better yeah the
Rock 10 times
so I could go on Tuesday now
like I didn't go today because I had
those two meetings but I knew I had
Tuesday and Wednesday and Wednesday I'll
go to the drill class tomorrow I do
kettlebells
well did any like is a lot of the
reaction I saw like the vast majority of
it was positive and and not even the
negative reaction but like sometimes
like some people are like wow that's I'm
surprised like it was it did any of that
motivate you like why are they surprised
that I could do this no I wasn't
surprised no I didn't take anything
negatively
I know what I'm doing is good and I'll
tell you why because let's pretend I go
to class twice a week okay you do 40
[__] push-ups
every time you're in class that means
I'm doing any more push-ups than if I
didn't go there that means I'm doing 80
more jumping jacks that means I'm doing
any more sit-ups that means I'm doing
any more [__] uh uh triangles that
means I'm doing 80 [__] uh hip
escapes that means I'm doing 80 of those
[__] things where you stretch your
arm out to reach you know that means I'm
doing so many [__] things I wasn't
doing
I'm getting that from the program 20
push-ups 24 for 80 push-ups 80 [__]
uh squats you know and then you drill
even if I was a [__] pansy even if I
said well I don't want to [__] Spar
because I'm an actor
I think when I went there they also
looked at the actor aspect of it
you know there's a lot of actors that
are in these classes up here so they
walk in there late
they [__] get on the phone halfway
through the thing everything's they're
important I never act that way at all I
don't go to class unless I'm there 15
minutes before class
I do the warm-ups Ike's finished class I
never have to leave if I have a meeting
at 12 45 I just won't go to class and
insult the class
you know but that's from my karate days
that's how it was you don't show up
[__] late don't show up dog
don't even show up we don't give a [__]
about your excuse
like that's all those little things make
you a better person in real life
I know it probably varies but is there
like a core group of people who go to
the same noon classes Monday Wednesday
yes yes how much go Tuesday and Thursday
because they have jobs or oh yeah
absolutely but like how like when you
were saying you don't want to disrespect
the class by like showing a blader being
on the phone
there's something when there's a group
like that for for at least in my
experience like as soon as a phone gets
taken out like everyone starts looking
like it's it's very noticeable like so
people think oh it's just a phone like
who's gonna care no when you're working
out hard it's like when someone I don't
want I don't know if it's disrespectful
it probably is but from it's just it
just it's very noticeable well it sticks
out you know I've been to gyms in
Beverly Hills dog
where you know everybody walks in
they're on the [__] phone loud
they don't give a [__] if you're doing a
jumping jack they don't give a [__] what
you're doing
you know they put their [__] gee on
they don't warm up they go in there they
do two moves and I saw it and then they
get up and I got a meeting at one
o'clock so that's it
you're more important than us
all because they're that they don't they
miss the warm-up and you just struggled
through the one moment well I I lived
the struggle for the long yeah my
warm-up is my hyperventilation so I live
to [__] struggle through it by the
time I'm getting up I'm sweaty Fat's
burning
I could smell the [__] bacon around
my ass burning you know I could smell it
you could you know you could just you
start sweating man I love that whole
aspect of it this is a martial art is
not about karate and killing people
it's kind of like the respect you have
for people but more important the
respect you have for yourself that makes
you have respect for people you commit
you're a new guy I'm not gonna try to
punch you in the face
I'm gonna tell you what to put your hand
and do all those things and even if I
don't get the work that I want to my
workout was teaching you today
you know the first day of class making
you go home feeling good about yourself
or because someone did that for you on
your first day sure a lot of people did
it for me a lot of [__] people did it
for me you know
so all these little things are what
that's about
it's a way of giving a little piece of
yourself getting a guy on top you're
going to do this grab that shoulder do
this choke and you take a little choke
but you're teaching him you you let him
[__] smell it you know what I'm
saying you're letting him smell it
so uh I'm really proud I'm proud I got
it I'm Gonna Keep [__] going like I
said for me it was more of an example
thing for my family
so when she gets older she sees I do
something three times a week come snow
rain you do it and your children start
watching and gonna [__] you do that
Daddy Mom doesn't have to be jiu jitsu
it could be a karate class it could be a
class about [__] Electronics
could be anything
your kids aren't going to want to do
that stuff and then I'm going to see you
doing it Danny why do you go to class
you're an old man because I want to
learn
the [__] enthused about learning wow
you still you know whatever
the [__] it is
you're just not sitting there watching
TV like the general American [__]
family
and they get enthused can you take me
with you
is there classes for kids yeah they got
a [__] math class at night for kids
and boom there you go
are you doing something with your child
was that done with you wasn't done with
[__] me
and I didn't invent this I just thought
of I just thought that that's why I got
into jiu jitsus I got into Jiu Jitsu two
months after she was born three months
after she was born wow yeah yeah yeah
May
of 2013. my mom wasn't she was always
really big on like I never had Summers
off
like I I from the time I can remember I
was either at a camp
at like uh like honestly if I think
about it even though I ended up hating
the camp I went to this like arts
program once like this Art summer thing
and it was all nerds but I took all of
the video production courses and then
from there I went to high school and
took all those and then went to college
so I used to hate it because all my
friends would be at home watching TV she
always had you busy yeah she always had
me busy
um but then
like it's
that's a lot of pressure to put on
yourself as a parent
to like have to like set it like always
we set an example well what's the
pressure the pressure is either set the
[__] example
or pay for it when you're the 22 and
you're 60. and now you're having a mini
heart attack every time they [__] go
on the phone rings
you're following trying to say to you
man right yeah you know that's how you
take your child and teach them little
[__] things
it's not by making them read a book or
[__] what he's going to learn on
fuckingabc.com
it's gonna be from what he learns from
you as a parent
you know listen man like I said I [__]
up as a parent the first time so it's
very important to me this time
I might die to [__] Morrow but I'll
know that I did 100 by these
[__] here you following me and
that's part of the big picture
me going there at 12 o'clock every day
helps my whole life
it helps my fitness it helps my comedy
it helps my confidence
it helps my relationship with my wife
you know it does 92 things good even if
I don't get good at jiu jitsu
did you think did you ever think about
that
like that's why I'm addicted to it
because I know that I'll never be
bushesha and I know I'll never be John
Evans I know I'll never be half these
guys I hang out with it they Bravo but
it doesn't matter to me I just enjoy
going and learning something new every
day
you enjoy going and but there's a very
real possibility that you could be you
could become a black belt there's no
reason why not I don't even think that
way
even the blue doesn't even matter
like I'm embarrassed to go to class
tomorrow with that blue belt on the
little piece of me [__] yeah
I know I worked hard you know what I'm
saying but I don't feel like a [__]
blue Bop
but maybe this will you know sometimes a
mental thing gets the level going
there's a very very very
interesting show on HBO right now and
it's called in the night
I haven't even heard of it it's an old
show that was shot a couple years ago
with John determined in fact the
executive producers James Gandolfini
right that's about a kid who supposedly
rapes and kills a girl and they catch
him an Arab kid and he goes to jail
and it's funny because I watched it last
week I've been watching it since it
first came out episode one was slower
than [__] molasses
but I knew there was something there
when there's a show that slow there's
something there lizard building yeah
yeah they're just building and episode
two was really good and episode three
was really good and episode four was
fantastic
so now we're on to episode five
in episode 5 is basically about him
transforming in the pre in the jail
system now
now he's no longer in jail
now he's becoming a part of the jail
but it's funny because all last week
I did I did a podcast with somebody
about two weeks ago and they were asking
me if I ever had any problems when I
went to prison
and I told him honestly looking back I
never had not one problem
but there was one
that was one
and while I was telling the story
I I you know I got in the car later on
and I made calls to you and to my wife
but I kept thinking about that story
how this guy [__] with me from day one
but how I sucked him into a web and it
took me two months to catch him in the
laundry room
maybe three months it took me to catch
me in the laundry room do you know why
because when I walked in there I wasn't
a part of the [__] prison
but as I sat in there all those months
and I was surrounded with those Savages
I became them
you know and I was telling my wife that
I grabbed him you know I've never liked
long hair on guys there's a thousand
things I don't like on guys because if
you get into a fight an earring a nose
ring long hair slippers they could step
on my [__] toe and break it
you know there's a lot of things that
you can avoid you know I'm gonna fist
fight I'm a slick guy I'm older than you
you got a nose ring I'm ripping out your
[__] nose ring and that's the end of
the [__] fight right there you're
yelling and screaming for two hours down
the street or I'll just pull you by
you know that that's it you have to
fight why not so when I caught this kid
I caught him by the hair he didn't cat
you know
the person they tell you when you go to
when you get locked up is don't go into
weird places unless you have somebody
with you
so if I see you I'll go Lee walk me to
the laundry room let's talk
I'll give you a cigarette or whatever
the [__]
and you walk me for some reason this guy
was like there's Clicks in prisons you
know there's blacks and Puerto Ricans
and in this place it was blacks Mexicans
but there was two clicks for blacks
there was the graveyard blacks and there
was graveyard was a certain character
that was a crazy black dude then there
was the uh chicken chicken hot chicken
hawk
crew and I was part of that crew I was
friends and that crew from the kitchen
and it's one uh why was it called the
chicken hawk because that was his name
chicken hawk
his name was Spencer Antoine but they
call them chicken hawk he was from New
Orleans and he was in there for [__]
um
what do you call that [__] manslaught
so he was the leader of that crew he was
really [__] crazy his eye was crooked
I loved him like an uncle then you had
the graveyard crew you had to be careful
with them they were hard-hitting
[__] from like hoods in
California and [__] they were all like
Crips and bloods and [__] all this
other [__] combined and you didn't
really mess with them I talked to them
but I didn't message them I didn't go to
their reunions or nothing no hot dog
it's serious why the [__] go over
that the graveyard gang yeah that was
his name graveyard because he killed so
many people so they just called him a
[__] graveyard I didn't know they had
reunions though yeah that little party's
five or six of the black dudes would
jump up and down and play dominoes and
drink
and then they had this white crew which
you know there's a white and they
weren't white supremacists they're just
white but then there was this little
motorcycle [__] little crew and he
was part of that [__] dummy crew and
the leader dummy was this dude I can't
remember what his name was
[__] he was old he was [__] my age
now wrinkled always stunk like [__]
leather and [__]
because she could wear your clothes or
jail clothes and he would still wear his
leather in there I don't even know who
he was affiliated with
and there's a bunch of other stinky
dudes around them and then you have like
this the white crew I was tight with
because I was tight with John Clark and
me and John clock at the speed a couple
of times on Mondays and went to play
basketball John clock was a bad
[__] people had known him in
there
the point of the [__] story is that
it took me three months to get crazy
like really [__] prepared for it like
I got into a fist fight and then I got
kind of beat up they broke it up because
we knew each other in the age unit but
by that point I was still kind of soft
this guy was [__] me he's the guy
that took a [__] in the box and put in
his draw those uh those [__] uh
government cheese boxes I took a
government cheese box took a [__] in it
and put an American flag in it and put
the Box in and put it in his [__]
drawer and he would ask people smell my
room
does it smell weird in here and finally
after like a month he found it and the
piece of [__] must have been 12 inches
when I dropped it had shriveled up like
hey it's just the flag killed over the
three soldiers couldn't even hold it up
no more and [__] the flag had killed
though from the fumes he was [__]
furious and he knew it was me and he's
in there for manslaughter no the white
dude was in there for something stupid
dirty head I did with the long hair that
was [__] with me yeah and you know
that with the bike is I don't know what
he was in there for I never really
[__] became friends with him and then
he would make little remarks I know the
[__] put this cheese in my drawer I'm
gonna look watch your back he would say
that [__] so I watched I never forget it
was cold
and the steam was coming out of your
breath
right and I watched them that morning I
don't know why I was sitting by the
library steps and I'm watching the
laundry room and I see him I got a
basket
and when I went to see him go got a
basket I shot to the AIDS unit
because the Aging it was next to the
laundromat and I popped my little
[__] head out to see if he was coming
to the laundry room by himself
and there he was
like a little guppy coming to a shark
he just came right to me so I jumped in
the [__] laundry room there and I
just waited and when he turned that
corner I just grabbed one side of his
handle and wrapped it and you should
have seen his funky little eyes and I
grabbed this other [__] side of his
head and grabbed that point by that
point he was slow he still was holding
onto the laundry basket poor bastard he
didn't even see what crawled up on him
and I just kept banging his head off the
[__] wall until he just went down I
just walked out there like nothing
happened he never even said nothing
that's what I had become because I'm
surrounded by it it's not who the [__] I
was I mean I was a little [__] I was
a little crazy I could be known for
doing stupid [__] like that but that's
that's what's going on with this show
right now so this week the [__]
they called him into a thing some guy
threw gas at him or something they made
him punch the guy and he punched the guy
and he turned around the guy kept
talking [__] he started beating the [__]
out of him
this is how brilliant this show is they
show the transformation then five
minutes later they show them shaving his
[__] head
getting bald like [__] taxi driver
like Travis Bickle and tragedy died
whatever his [__] name is uh-huh so
they starting to show his transformation
I don't know how many episodes they
actually have
they're up to episode five so I really
don't know well how
what are what is the type of person like
who's like the leader of a jailhouse
gang
or like what's that person like when you
meet them well first of all they're not
really
a leader or something like that it's not
like they like the black dude Antoine
Spencer Antoine Spencer was in there
for uh manslaughter and he got 12 years
cut to six
but
he was very quiet he read
he was loud in the kitchen you know
they're black dudes
so in my world it was him and this dude
from Buffalo that had their own little
black crew
what do I mean by that they shared food
night we would go over and watch a game
or Antoine would sneak something out of
the kitchen and we'd go to his [__]
room you know Antoine's
but a room was maybe four rooms away
from mine because they put the kitchen
workers all together
uh okay and I had beef with dirty head
dirty headed even work in the kitchen
and they put them in those barracks
it's like God put him in those [__]
Barracks for me to [__] pull his hair
and bang his head off the wall like he
was the only non-kitchen worker that was
in those barracks
Jesus
but so what you're saying though is like
so it wasn't like the movies or TV
yeah no no no or like he's giving orders
and like they bring him stuff no no no
no no no not even like this show I'm
watching now I've never seen it to that
extent maybe in the deep Deep D prisons
you have that I don't think it's that
dramatic
but the
the white dude the white dude gang
pretty much they all bowed down to John
Clark John Clark had money John Clark
had been through the system John Clark
was a badass John Clark Got Drugs in
jail John Clark had a great old lady
John Clark had what all those guys
didn't have
so they all bowed down and John Clark
you know the black dude had a big
support if you have a lot of support in
prison people see that
and they kind of navigate towards you
because they don't have that support
what do you mean to go from outside
people respect that a lot if you have a
lot going in from the outside
there's people who have nothing coming
in from the outside they have no you
know their parents cut them off
they don't have a girlfriend no more
they don't see their wife their wives
are divorcing them they start dating
their friends it's a [__] horrible
this horrible situations and it's like
the nail in the coffin you know what I'm
saying you got arrested you lost your
job now you're in prison now while
you're in prison your wife called you
and says hey I'm dating your friend or
you know we don't want you around no
more your kids don't want you you know
what I'm saying that there's some really
great support systems and there's no
support systems and people see that
people navigate towards money
people navigate towards that
yeah because I mean how
how like how much of your life
requires you to have money or something
in person like if you if you had no
money coming in and no job what would
prison be like
it'd be out
it'd be hell with no support
you know again I find
you know I have all these things in my
head that I have this anger within my
ex-wife but again even though all the
hatred I had towards her
she was there for me when I was locked
up
she's the camera paper she's a cam my
banking she took care of the [__]
bills
she went by the apartment you know
so that helps out a lot you know
somebody put 20 on your books
somebody to come see you on Sunday that
helps out a [__] a lot you know
that's why I still write Phil
you know he's in jail
I write
I try to write them every [__] 10
days
because I know it'll as soon as I write
Phil
four days later I got a letter back from
him
he's excited in the weather
you know because I know any friend of
mine who got locked up by trying to mail
them letters
ten dollar money order whatever you
could do because I know it makes their
[__] day pictures
you know tickets from a comedy show
whatever Phil gets [__] happy
and that's why I do that because I
remember myself getting letters when I
went to prison I started writing a lot
more letters
I really found the power of the letter
you know even though I could so what I
would do is Lee I call you first time
and go yeah you heard and you go yeah
have you meant anything to me I get your
address before I hung up
and I'd start writing you letters and it
would make you write me letters
but wow so you were you would write
letters
like how many would you write a day
you know I would just write them I
didn't have a lot of people to write
I was writing a few people in New Jersey
apologizing to them
I would write to uh
my girlfriend's dad
I was communicating with him a lot
through letters he liked it I was
communicating with uh my girlfriend
through letters and on the phone you
know we were talking the phone and write
letters to each other and
oh
the other people who you didn't tell
like obviously now with the podcast and
stuff people most people probably know
but did you were you trying to maybe
keep it a secret from anybody
no because
I knew at first I didn't want the people
in North Bergen to find that
because I didn't want them to say see we
told you
right yeah
that's the worst one that's the [__]
worst and I mean I got arrested two
years after I left North berg
and the word spread like wildfire I got
the rest of the kidnapping
that's people were toasting
really people are toasted
saying like told you so yeah you know
people were [__] toasting I never
thought about that do you regret leaving
North Bergen or do you think you would
have got arrested there too I would have
got arrested I would have got killed in
Westberg
all honesty
all [__] honesty
without even thinking about it now
thinking about it and talking to
sabatina all the other day and talking
to my friends yeah
I was going it was just a matter of time
I had done too many little things and it
was starting to add up
people who mattered kept hearing my name
you know when I go I don't stop it's
like anything else I don't stop
think if I didn't have the podcast my
wife the baby comedy Jiu Jitsu and all I
did was snort coke and steel what would
I be likely
I'd be this crafty
only doing everything illegal
so you would hear about me every [__]
day I was up to something
Jesus
every day just some but and then there's
no rules like when it's illegal so you
could you could go crazy listen those
last
18 20 months I spent North Bergen every
time something got robbed I got the
blame
let's pretend I erupts 80 percent of it
but I got blamed for everything
everything there was a time if a car got
stress scratched
I got blamed for everything
if I was in the vicinity I got blamed
I remember Jimmy Burkle who brought me
that Colorado
he went back to Jersey I was in Colorado
and I haven't been talking to him on the
phone he goes you're not gonna I guess I
can't believe you called we're just
talking about you like what happened he
goes my mother's house got robbed in
North berg
and somebody brought up and he goes it
can't be him he's in Colorado I talk to
him every week
but that made me think about it like
that was [__] five years later
that was like 1994 I was already out of
jail and [__]
ten years and you know he told me he
goes it's funny you called
my mother's house got robbed over the
weekend up in North Bergen
and I thought it was you Jesus not the
mother somebody brought up it could have
been Coco and he goes no uncle's in
[__] Colorado he wouldn't do this
anybody would Rob my mother
it
it's really like whenever I think about
jail or prison it's like my worst
nightmare
and listen to you talk and then just
looking at you and just
where you where you are now it's when I
hear jail or prison I just think life is
over no matter if it's for a day or 200
years
it's just that's how it makes me think
but it like
it looks like it's possible to like have
like a life after prison which is if you
would have asked me before I met you I
would have said there's not like what do
you mean life after prison
I would have assumed it was over
what is it what's that word called
recidivism yeah
you have to look up the national
recidivism rate
to see how many felonies
to a person sees his value in life you
know
and that's a lot it takes a lot it takes
a lot for some people
you know it took that situation in
Colorado
and then another situation in Seattle
which could have got really ugly and it
didn't
to scare the bejesus out of me Jesus
oh my God I also thought what you think
also like most Americans like most
people listen to this podcast yeah that
if you go to prison you're done for
eight years four years five years
you know I watch a lot of Law and Order
whenever you come over I watch a lot of
Law and Order and I think about those
sentences
whenever they give somebody 15 years
even though it's just television I still
when the episode ends I still think that
for five minutes ago 16 years
16 [__] years
you know you know what that's like
that's two thousand to now what were we
doing in 2000 I was in sixth grade can
you imagine nope 16 [__] years of
your time when they told me nine years I
almost [__] my [__] pants
I was I thought
I never saw this
I never saw this when I went to prison I
thought I'd have a life
but I didn't see
anything positive
like I thought the rest of my life was
going to be hard when I came out of
prison
like you'd be like like that's yeah a
Subway work like my biggest fear no I
wouldn't yeah like a Subway worker like
somebody struggling you know somebody
addicted to drugs which I was somebody
uh
that was always struggling you know I
would live in an apartment with three
guys and
you know I wasn't like a constant head
or one of those guys that wanted to be
cool but I never really thought I'd have
a together
let's be [__] honest that's why
comedy in the beginning was so easy it
was no responsibility
it was a car and you it was a [__]
pretty decent car and you
you didn't need a house you got a PO box
and you got a pager
and that's it that's comedy
that's [__] simple
to disappear
it's that simple
you look so you you could have been on
the road forever like it was that a
maybe a thing like maybe I'll I'll be a
road comic forever just doing uh I
didn't want that double gigs trouble
ones I did not want that
I did not want that
I did not want to be
55 and to say
you know LA's for [__] [__]
I didn't live there because whatever I
rather do this [__] and just party and
drink every week on the road and tell
stories about
partying with Kennison or Led Zeppelin I
didn't want to do that either no it's I
don't want to be that guy on the road
either that's not a [__] life
everyone thinks it's a loser do you want
to hear I have the receiving this mates
I can't say that it's it's a it's a lot
it's uh and this one's from o5 what's
the most recent one I could find
um within three years about two-thirds
get re arrested
so in three years two-thirds and then uh
within five years about 75 percent
are back in So within five years 75 of
people all right so I got let out
and 91 out of the system and I got
arrested again in 95.
but knock on wood I've never got
arrested again I'm not going wood
knock on wood and now those arrests in
Seattle would just the tail end of the
case of death
it was the tail end of
life showing me how easy this is if you
recognize it and move on you're smarter
than this [__] and that's exactly what
happened
well I mean that's true but how lucky we
were just giggling about it but how
lucky are you they're the Guardians you
hit long whatever that dirty hairs guy
name was like you could have gotten 10
years out of your sentence
or something no but I knew where all the
guides were all right we're right right
and there was no cameras in those days
like there are today but but something
another president that happens a lot is
getting time added once you're in prison
yes yes yes and it was very fortunate
and then let me tell you something let's
get something straight okay
from [__] 90 to 95.
I did not live on a [__] thin line by
no means
okay I lived
I wasn't the old Coco
but I wasn't reformed either I still had
the [__] seven year scratch
I was still not and that's why nothing
was going right
because I was still borrowing from Peter
to pay Paul
you know we talked about this on this
podcast constantly when you borrow from
Peter to pay Paul you could do it for
three or four years eventually the walls
crash on you you could play that drug
game for years
I would play it and give myself a time
frame when I had to be out of town
I knew it I knew when it was coming to
an end
you know I had done it I had done it so
many [__] times
what happened was from 90 to 95 was I
kept pushing the envelope but I pushed a
low envelope I pushed the misdemeanor
envelope
or whenever I would go rob at those
places I'd keep it on the 400.
you know what I'm saying like whenever I
would return stuff I keep it on the 400
that's misdemeanors all day long
you understand what I'm going to say to
you so I did a little things you knew
the limit yeah if somebody came to me
and said we want to buy an ounce of coke
I don't know what you're talking about
at least sayak came up to me who I know
and I see snort every [__] day come
up to me and says I need April I would
try to make a small 50 on you I was
always on the move
and if that didn't work I'd go to a pen
store and rob a bunch of cross pens and
sell them to Car Sales
I always knew how to flip a [__]
dollar
worst case scenario you get your [__]
wedding band important and get 100 bucks
and get an ounce of weed to start
selling it or whatever this is this is
my mentality this was my mentality
this is why you never get ahead of
yourself you never get ahead when you
have that mentality
once I gave my heart to Comedy and I
said you know what I can't have that in
my life anymore this is the route I'm
Gonna Leave
but it still followed me
you know dice comes on and dice reminds
me
of my first 18 months in L.A they were
also very not too happy
they were not the nice [__] days for
me
you know I still had to strip a
girlfriend
I had a beef I had three or four beefs
at The Comedy Store you know he told the
stories
I had a beef with
uh
these bookies these fake [__] New
York City bookies I had to get a gun and
go get money from them with Josh Wolf
I got a thousand stories that happened
in those 18 months once 99 came and
Carol left
that was it she took the kiss of death
from me
she was the kiss of death
it was five years of debt and they were
all her
some people are just like that two
people just don't get along they create
a weird energy
you know I just it was that's it yeah
you know how Joe Rogan says it one day I
got funny
right yeah Carolyn
that was it I didn't have to that my
energy from her
had shifted
just her her just the fact that she was
gone it was immediately you she changed
[__]
gone everything changed 22 pounds were
lifted off my [__] that's why
sometimes you don't know what's really
bothering it could be a simple
relationship
you know you don't know I knew it had to
end
but I was addicted to it I was like we
had great sex we had good times when we
were together it was just a three-day
effect we just hated each other
on the [__] third day you know what
I'm saying
and yeah but it's amazing that give me
five
it's amazing that that like just being
in a bad relationship can affect you
that much that much
like that much my anger rates I had a
lot I was going through on personal
level with addiction I had a lot I was
going through on a personal level with
my first daughter in that marriage I was
[__] broke I was striving to do
comedy I couldn't get ahead then I had
this [__] broad you know tormented in
my life
and the sad thing was I let her
by staying with her at that age
absolutely
so [__] lutely but you look at these
things later on
and you reflect on them and you help
people you talk to people who I was in a
situation like that one time
well I love it look listen pack your
[__] bags
you know sometimes you don't see it
sometimes we don't see these human
beings what's going on and it happened
to me twice
having me twice happened to me when I
got married
I've said this to you a thousand times
when I got married
as soon as I got married everything
changed I went into this [__]
depression I was yearning for something
it wasn't drugs I thought it was
religion I made my confirmation I did
this I did that I didn't know what the
[__] was going on we broke up it was
like a [__] door opened
wow so does that happen now but
obviously not with your wife maybe but
maybe like other things in your life so
like I was interested if like something
starts going long in your life if you
start looking at different aspects of
your life to see where the problem could
be
always
as you get older you start looking at
how does this affect me right you know I
was thinking about how November 7th or
whatever the [__] day it is I'm going
to nine years
what I'm doing blow
and this is what I can tell you you've
heard all my stories right right in
those 27 years of all those disgusting
drug stories uh-huh
either as much has happened in these
last nine are being sober without those
type of drugs in that type of
environment
and they've all been a positive thing
a lot of funny [__] we've seen a lot of
funny [__] when I farted outside by the
lady and she walked into a fart I was
thinking about that today yeah we've
done a lot of funny [__] I'm not saying
that we're completely innocent right you
know we've met on the Jehovah Witnesses
I seen Jehovah's today and waved at him
and threw a kiss at him they started
walking I ran upstairs there's no
apartment they were knocking downstairs
I'm still an evil [__] I never said that
but it's that other side it's that
thwart I was involved in this circle of
[__] never-ending
[__]
whatever I'm involved in something
that's not organic
that's what it backfires on mainly
that I'm organically doing it for all
the right reasons
and just you're not just doing it to do
it or if it doesn't when I fell in love
with Terry
even though I wasn't doing the right
things on the outside of the
relationship I was doing the right
things with her
I was talking to her the right way I was
trying to
do the best I can at that time
and this is why I have this today
because I really really fell in Loveland
I really really liked it
from the beginning there was no by the
way
with Kathy it was a by the way
and with characters and by the way
and to be honest here there was a bold
by the ways
and that's something by the way to go
into a relationship with you know
but it's
how do you tell someone to get out of
one like that's that must be a tough
conversation to have to tell who anyone
anyone who can't tell somebody that's on
my [__] business they have to see it
Leon and sometimes it takes four years
sometimes it takes 10 years sometimes it
takes 90 days
each of us are completely [__]
different in what we'll tolerate
right no I but we're definitely won't
tolerate but
if I mean if I was in a bad relationship
I'd want to know
how could I tell
unless you come over to my house crying
with a black eye every [__] night I
can't [__] tell right that's true you
know so that that's the thing
I can't really see into nobody could see
into what was going on with me
until I got [__] arrested
you know with her and then I went
backward and every time I'd be with her
a month later I get [__] arrested
I've been with thousands of women I
never got [__] arrested
and you can just just her being there
just makes you get a rest at all it was
just a bad energy man yeah yeah
sometimes two people just don't they
think they're making something happen
but they're really not
it's like you're taking two steps
forward one step back
right well you two very similar as
people yeah yeah I had a girlfriend
there was drugs involved both of us did
drugs listen I've never a relationship
has never worked for me when we both
done drugs
either I'm a smoker and she's a drinker
or vice versa
every relationship I've had that there
was cocaine alone that didn't want they
don't around no more you see him around
no I don't see anyone no no no no no not
at all
so you have to be with the right person
for the right reasons how the [__] do
you know do you think at 25 I [__]
know
I was at the wrong person I was in love
I thought I was in love I was hearing
this is what you got to hear in high
school this is what people do they move
in together they play house and
everything's going great and I laugh at
your jokes and I love you and I love you
and
this is what it's supposed to be I am
blown away by how many people I know who
are getting married and moving in and
already having kids
like I'm 28 I realize that that's not
too young for that so there's some
people like a lot of people are 28.
but to me I'm not anywhere near ready
for that like it scares the [__] out of
me let me ask you something
at [__] 50 do you think I was ready
for this
you're never ready for nothing Lee
you're never ready for nothing that's
what makes life life
I wish I could look at you and go you
know what I'm going to get married in 30
years and then after two more we're
gonna have children I'm gonna have a
little Nicholas and little [__] Nancy
and we're gonna dress them up together
who the [__] knows
nobody says to you we planned this no we
got drunk I banged them in the [__]
car and here we are
the difference is the difference is that
I didn't do was Is This Love or am I
getting married for a child
or am I getting married for convenience
okay these are the questions we never
ask ourselves
you follow I'm saying to you this is the
questions we don't ask ourselves
or just because you've been together
you're [__] making eight bucks an
hour right right you're fighting for
your [__] life the insurance people
looking for you you meet abroad she asks
you to move in with it you move in with
the [__] girl
she tells you not to pay rent why'd you
move in with a necessity
do you really [__] love it yeah you
might love it but you're there for
necessity now there's a problem
no she's got a hook on you
so the first thing that goes wrong guess
what's going to happen she's going to
[__] throw you out in the street
so when you move in with her the first
thing you better do is get yourself an
apartment on the side and start working
toward a [__] apartment so when she
grows yeah it's when you get that
apartment together you follow him saying
to you some people just have hooks in
you and that [__] so every time you get
together with somebody for a different
[__] hook for years I did that
for years we all get together for the
wrong people for the wrong reasons Bon
Jovi said it best I got lucky the first
time
I hope the same for you I hope the same
for everybody
but then there wouldn't be life there
wouldn't be divorces there wouldn't be
divorce attorneys there would be people
with stitches
there wouldn't be people who are
restraining all this where's Tony
Bennett [__]
the church [__] Monday August 8th you
want to go get them
hurry up hurry up
waiting around for confuses with your
little [__] comfortable
who's getting on the mic I want to use
quickly quickly yeah
thank you
nice look at the Box you brought me I
got no pens here I have the pens at the
house and I take the tubes from here put
them on the [__] plane serious but
these things
did I get some of those
my boys when you reek a vape right here
the ones I use that are really [__]
hit me on those long tubes you gave me
these are good
what's this here it's about 90 90.
what's this fantastic just suck on it
laughs
tremendous
the studios of my boys from Eureka Vape
we've been family for a long time tell
them talk to these [__] people what's
going on world getting close getting
close there yeah so we just came out
with the new uh clear addition to our
line of products and um it's taken off
fast it's uh pretty much pure THC okay
we're getting up to that 90 High 80
percent getting all the uh getting all
the byproduct out of there taking the
terpenes out reintroducing cannabis
terpenes back into the uh into the oil
to get the viscosity down so the Wicks
soak it up and then in turns gets to the
heating element and it's uh it's taking
off real good we're winning some awards
out there it's uh it's a fun times now
since I met you to now how much has the
blend changed
um as far as this new product the clear
with the short path machines and and uh
distillate what people are calling it we
have a slightly different process it's
uh it's just it's another edition of
machinery and and chemistry but as far
as the amble the Amber which is the
honey oil the CO2 honey oil that's the
same you know people are getting cute
out there and and doing the uh um
getting getting the um
add in the uh VG and the propylene
glycol and other stuff coconut oil what
you were saying you had a problem with
someone's back right some months people
give me a lot of vapors and people are
giving me [__] Ash and
and what happened was I was smoking it
so much
and then when I would go on the road I
wouldn't smoke weed with all that stuff
and I wasn't finding myself coughing
yeah and I realized all that [__] they
were [__] giving me
was kind of shitty yeah I could feel it
the next day I could feel like after a
weekend the smoke and a [__] vapor
pen and [__] you always you whenever you
had a vapor pan it used to give me a
headache like I've always gotten
headaches from them that's why I've
never really been a huge proponent of
them
it's like it's tough but yours like it
doesn't really happen we don't cut it
you know what do they cut it with
vegetable glycerin propylene glycol
coconut oil those are the three no I buy
a gram I buy a gram in one of those
[__] things how much
real [__] reefer am I getting from us
no from a regular compound Jesus it all
depends across the board some of them
you know the testing isn't
um isn't really uh there's no compliance
out here as far as testing in California
but uh I can tell you from the Colorado
operation people are averaging anywhere
from 20 to 50s you know and cutting and
with a lot of cut on there now whether
that test was before the cut got in
there or after
you know that's that's a good question
but you can taste it if anything's
tasting like cherries blueberries you
know it's cute but we don't know what
that long-term effect is going to be
here we are doing medicinal and we might
be giving giving people pneumonia water
in the lungs or there's there's a
there's a long list of things that
suppose it hap supposedly happens from
that we don't know because it's new the
e-cigarette
um stuff is new you know it's only blown
up in the past five years give or take
that's really hit mainstream and that's
what this is emulating the The Vapor
business is copying that so long-term
effect God knows you know we really
really don't know you know and it's hard
to say because then the um you hear
people saying that uh the E-Cigarettes
are getting uh polyps on their lungs and
stuff I don't know if that's true either
because the guy's been smoking a [__]
pack of cigarettes you know for three
thirty years whatever the case may be
and now it's the vapor it's getting made
you have the lung problem you know I
gave him up because I could feel it too
when I wouldn't smoke them and then when
I'd smoke them I could feel the
difference so the vapor wasn't working I
tell you what it's [__] really bad
those things that people put the [__]
juice in there and then blow the big
clouds those people might as well put a
gun to their [__] heads because you
really don't know what the [__] is in
there when they brought me that somebody
brought me that one time and I was like
what's this [__] well you take this and
you fill it up and once I gotta fill
something up that's where the party ends
all that [__] and have it because I got
paperwork I'm a comedian I write I come
back an hour later there's oil on my
[__] from your [__] bong I have a
heart attack dog I got [__] there I got
paperwork on top of the [__] desk so
I don't want no blow torches yeah you
know I don't want no dabs I don't want
no rocks in my [__] house I don't
want no explosives you know this is it's
it's
I'm old enough to see it this is listen
1980 people were jumping up and down in
studio 54. maybe the snorting cold
getting ass the [__] the vs that's it
and then four years later I'm in a hotel
room with a black guy and a hooker and
I'm [__] smoking [__] uh crack out
of a glass next thing you know I'm at
East West
and I bought the Free Base Kit you know
84. you could buy a free base kid at a
head shop the glass of Silk Stocking to
blow torch the [__] all these things
and I took it and we went to my friend's
basement and we must have went through
11 grams and I couldn't believe what a
wasted time it was so wait a second we
were having a great time here you'd do a
line I do a line I put a line on your
[__] you put a line on my helmet we
suck each other off and we go home now I
gotta go upstairs cook it
pull it through a [__] sock let it
dry patiently and then I gotta put on
the thing and it disappears like that
disappears like that what happened to
the coke I don't have no [__] so it's
always something like once I saw that I
go I'm done
I'm gonna snort coke till 2007. I'm
never gonna smoke it I'm never I never
fell for nothing else I fell one time
then like in
87 these [__] Savages at clubs in New
York City were taking coke with which is
the same thing uh
baking soda and you put in the microwave
oven and you take the rocks out and you
then you take nicotine out of your
cigarette and you put the [__] thing
in your cigarette and you light it up
and next thing you know you were seeing
Godzilla I didn't like cigarettes then
so people like you do the same with
reefer so they would put the coke rocks
and then get a lighter and you burnt
Under The Joint you could see the coke
spreading onto the paper and you'd smoke
those [__] things it was over there
were Bazookas but you know what people
are losing their [__] houses over
that [__] yeah that's where the ad
started oh yeah you know it was like a
thousand ways to smoke crack yeah but
nobody could figure out you're smoking
crack you know I mean listen the [__]
you buy on 188th Street is not the [__]
we were doing I mean the [__] you buying
180th Street is the [__] you buy is the
[__] you find in the oil business here
in California there's no compliance so
in the crack business they take a pound
of coke and they get you know three
pounds of crack but they cut it with
turpentine you know what that's like
you know people say well I don't have no
lung capacity I started blow for 27
years they cut that [__] with gasoline
what do you think that did to the inside
of my lungs I got no little flamboyant
amoeba has left I got nothing
yeah whatever the [__] you call those
when you smoke you got little heads my
hands are done that thing is balding and
[__] Joe Rogan that thing is my lungs
are bald Jack so
now talk to me about
I had a CBD I love all this stuff you
know I love smoking I love getting
[__] high
uh
you know like I said we got people that
I'll go to a weed store or something to
go Joey somebody left you something
hmm
they know you come here take this and
I'll smoke it and I'll go in fact
somebody gave me
a vape and a try but they gave me your
cartridge
I didn't realize it until I got to the
hotel room and I opened the envelope
they gave it to me an envelope and you
actually have to text the number and if
you like The Vape
but the funny thing was they gave me
your bottom
I was like this is [__] interesting
so they gave me their fluid with your
bottom poaching [__] poaching
[__] so you guys were here in
California and then we spoke about a
year ago and you were headed to Colorado
and every 90 days we're talking about
Colorado and you were like holy [__] and
I told you the first time I go listen
those that come that's a complete
different world
and for them to survive
they got to be whiter than white
if it's an inch they stick to it
it's uh it's a great it's a great City
you know we did a licensing deal out
there with the group and uh we set it uh
set it up and staffed it but it's uh
it's running like a well-loyal machine
the um tough Market out there you know
it's a very developed the uh the biggest
guy in in my part of the uh industry is
from there that's his backyard and um
it's uh it's interesting I've made a lot
of good good people out there the CBDs
out there is huge too you know they're
doing these uh down in Pueblo they're
doing these hemp Farms you know Acres
upon Acres upon acres and there and it's
really going to kick up in the next uh
year or two but as far as the uh the lab
that that was built down there it's um
state of the art it's real it's really
when did you build yeah yeah which I
what I helped build with the uh with the
owner and um we got about 4 900 square
feet almost 5 000 square feet
um they got they're running two
custom-made uh Apex 20 machines
and their producing they're about to
come out with the clear the machine that
we have Colorado's never seen the
machine so it's in Denver fire
department's hands right now from I
understand they were telling me it's the
last phase before it gets uh the uh the
stamp and will be up and running
hopefully they'll be I I'm hoping within
three to six weeks something like that
you know it's [__] booming out there
Joey I mean you look across the skyline
it's just it's like downtown it's almost
it's almost not as bit much as downtown
LA down here but I was like holy geez so
um anyway that's the production out
there is uh is going they're making some
traction some waves because the big
difference is again we're introducing
cannabis terpenes back into it now let
me give you a little thing here at sea
level right the viscosity oils no
problem just put the raw oil right into
the cartridge and and the wick soaks it
up and gets to the heating element well
when you're at 5 000 plus elevation and
the high desert the iron no humidity
this stuff is like molasses out there
you need it to be like a maple syrup now
let's do it but break it down for you so
we figured out how to get the uh we had
the Cannabis terpenes like I said and we
introduced about about nine percent back
into it you know to loosen it up to get
it to the maple syrup state so it can
get soaked up by the wick and the uh as
you would say the flavor is tremendous
it's it's serious it's serious and it's
in uh people don't even know what to do
not to what to do it's uh
they haven't tasted something like that
out there now got to be quite honest
with you because we entered a blind uh
People's Choice
um contest it was called the 710 sesh
out there blind hands down Landslide
Victory you know they didn't know who we
were what it was it was not even a close
second according to the guy that was
throwing the contest the guy that was
throwing the contest he decided to enter
us into the shadow category
we play second I said [__] did we wind
up in this how do we wind up in the
shadow why not Shadow or oil because it
was better than a shadow and the only
reason you win is because you guys were
oil swear to God I was like I was like
okay you guys are on to something I
guess the guy that I that stay off the
place that's managed and he figured out
what to do so it was it was good and
then uh you know the uh outside is
coming in you know it's uh not always
the easiest thing you know the New Kids
on the Block yeah we might have a name
here but uh for the New Kids on the
Block over there but it's uh it's good
I'm I'm feeling confident for these guys
what are you going back to Denver
um I'll be back there next week so I
won't see you this weekend no I was
looking forward to seeing you guys this
weekend I don't know I'll be there
Thursday Friday to Saturday jumping up
and down so I could just imagine
how [__] crazy like I've been there
maybe three times since this is going on
and I've seen the the three day effect
it's like when you go to New York City
yeah I'm going for three days how much
can you really see you see the outskirts
you know what I'm saying I still haven't
gone back to Boulder and seen what that
shit's like and how the weed stores are
there or something I love to go to
Greeley I love to go to all my old
[__] Hornets Longmont and yeah just
to see now what time do this weed stores
stay open till um depending on what part
of like Denver is uh I want to say seven
o'clock
and then other parts like uh Glendale
uh which is Cherry Creek Water they're
they're midnight a few places 10 10
o'clock
it's uh they get they got a good thing
they're open at nine in the morning
bright and early there's another the few
and far between them are an open nine in
the morning interesting thing is you go
down to those border towns these guys
are seeing a thousand fifteen hundred
customers a day
a day and you pull up to this place and
you're like there's nothing around where
are these people coming from what are
they you know living on the Rocks
literally
they're coming in across the borders
yeah across the border stuff yeah now
there's a lot of open land in Colorado
could you just buy up like because like
I've driven through it could you just
buy like a land out on the highway and
just build the weed store out there no
no no no no it's not it's not that easy
at all they're not uh the Market's a
little saturated which actually the uh
ZIP code that we're in in the Denver
proper was is considered a saturated zip
code and uh people people are fighting
back and forth but it the amount of
money it's bringing in you know there's
a 23 24 tax on the uh sale of
recreational
there's not a bad freaking School
District in the city you know roads are
good you know it's it's beautiful it's
building and I'm not it's obviously it's
not all the marijuana it's a good
portion you got the tech boom you know
Google's coming out there and so forth
but it's it's something to see man
beautiful city good people it's uh it's
it's uh food is good too you've been
there during Bronco season yeah
people go [__] crazy when they won oh
man yeah people go [__] crazy I was
there when they were losing I was there
those years when they would have parties
and parades and uh [__] explosives
and they'd have a Super Bowl party and
[__] loose
so I
this is what I gotta tell you like
I grew up in New York City and I had
great weed I had to go into Harlem to
get like chocolate Thai weed and [__]
when I went to Colorado it was a
complete different world for me I went
to Colorado as a 19 year old
holy [__]
and I was getting [__] stoned in that
[__] altitude I was getting [__]
ripped up the first time I smoked was
out of a bong and I passed out and asked
me
went backwards they had to wake me up
with ice on my head and [__]
so now if this liquid is going to get
clear
that is clear this is clear yeah that's
the clear
now what is this here this is a sativa
indica
sativa indica
and that's yours
this is very [__] nice
it's uh
I'm proud of these guys they did some uh
heavy work man
a lot of r d goes into this [__] let me
tell you what I do with these I can't
smoke them all day but in the hotel
rooms in the mornings I get blasted with
these
I get blasted to the point where like I
forget I gotta go eat breakfast
remember when I get up when I get up in
those hotel rooms on Friday and Saturday
if I don't have radio
first thing I do is got a cup of coffee
out of the [__] thing I darken it up
but they want four cups just one cup so
it's [__] strong no matter what it is
hotel brand Savoy Duke whatever the [__]
it is it's coming out blasting
while I'm drinking the coffee
I roll a joint to take downstairs
however long it takes me to take that
joint downstairs I'm digging around the
computer I'm [__] around on Twitter
I'm writing jokes I'm writing my daily
routine
sometimes I look up from smoking your
Vape man it's 10 o'clock
I've been sitting there for two hours I
gotta go down because breakfast and I
shut down at 11. you know what I'm
saying but that's how strong this week I
put it on the Periscope I did it in the
hotel room with the [__] thing and
for some reason I got two tubes one hits
harder than the other one the other two
down to the end but it's those old
school cartridges those long ones you
left me something here that was really
dynamite in there I don't know what the
[__] I took all of them out of that box
I yanked all those [__] out
there
tremendous tremendous [__] so now what
do you have in Colorado can I walk into
your store or you you sell them to
different stores where wholesalers uh
that's a it's a lab it's a manufacturing
lab
um and we are doing tours we hooked up
with uh um these uh limo services they
pick you up at the airports and they
drive you around and give you the tool
and then drop you off at a bottom
breakfast
um high-end toys is one
um that I'm really uh I really like
working with these guys and now what
they do is they they pick you up at the
airport they bring you to my facility
and um you told the facility you see
what's uh what what the moving parts are
we give you the whole Lowdown and then
they and then we take you to uh a grow
if there's time is you know it depends
and then what they're doing uh they got
a pretty good thing too a pre-fixed menu
like you know because you go into these
stores
you know somebody see your this is your
backyard you know these stores you know
in and out so you know what you like it
what you don't but then you bring 30 40
people off a bus and you put them into
this thing they don't know what the kid
in the candy store is an understatement
they're like what's this what's that so
they want to set it set it up and get
them the best of everything and prefix
menus and it's uh it's working out
pretty well
it's working out this high-end high-end
tours now how long has it been legal
two years a little over two years I
gotta be honest with you this is gonna
kill you guys
about three years ago I got hit up by
some kid listening to the podcast
and he was like listen man I go to
school in Boulder
you know I've been talking to my friends
we have an idea where we uh he doesn't
want to pick people up he wanted to
for me to pick people up in the car and
drive into different weed stores and
take them to a bar and take them to
dinner and
he had a couple of investors this is
crazy and he goes I'd love for you to be
one of the drivers I was like when would
I find time to do this you know what I'm
saying like when would I find time to do
this and he didn't [__] stop like he
was hitting me up he was hitting Rogan
up he was hitting me up he was sitting
bro you know I have no desire to be a
driver you know I mean not right now
where were you 10 years ago like to
[__] use it now I don't want to
[__] drive around and I don't get I
didn't want to drive for myself
you know so
hopefully it was one of these guys
they pick you up at the [__] airport
in the limo take it to a weed store and
then take it to a bud and breakfast
and you get to to my uh the facility
Eureka Vapors facility and see the
actual extraction process the lab
it's pretty uh now the bud and breakfast
break the button breakfast down to me I
want to hear about this [__] I think
well you pay for the room whatever x
amount of dollars and they have care
packages in there and you can and you
can indulge and have your little Edibles
and they show you where to go and they
have little uh excursions and I think
they even uh
I think they even souffle some food up
for you with uh infused products I'm not
exactly sure about that though
something else it's something else it's
[__] 2030 out there already like
they've already moved it that fast along
and they gotta and let's say you don't
want to stay in a hotel these guys can
hook you up with uh they have they have
uh um Partnerships with houses
apartments condos you know let's say you
know 15 guys you want to go to Aspen
they'll get you a mansion you know if
you want
so it's all in service they run it well
run it well very well I'm uh very
impressed on how they do it they they
move their operation around
and they got anything from 55 uh uh
people buses down to if you just wanted
a Cadillac truck you know
anything you want just me and Lee yes
there you go and just go to a [__]
weed store go to the extraction process
and just drop us off at the bud and
breakfast I got a Denali I'll pick you
up what's the best what's the best but
what's the best button breakfast and
like a smoke butt in the hotel room and
everything ah yes yeah no [__] and for
breakfast I go downstairs and during my
eggs I can just whip out a number and
it's all over but the [__] shouting
Jack right there in the breakfast room
there you go you know and
what
what most people understand is
I came from the standpoint of at least
been with me a thousand times Well I
want to join up
anywhere
like that fear left me 30 years ago
because I grew up in
late 70s early 80s in New York when
there was a thing called the [__]
junkies and they were everywhere and
they would fall asleep on the trains the
buses the [__] sidewalks waiting for
the light to change those were the best
they'd fall asleep waiting to just push
them over then they'd say who the [__]
pushed me I don't know man you didn't
nobody pushed you you [__] felt
[__] then you'd run away and [__]
they go come here you [__] whatever so
the smell of marijuana compared to this
Godzilla next to you at the [__] bus
that's not what a drool I mean they
would drool they would take their dicks
out and jerk off on the bus the [__]
70s were horrible in New York City I'm
horrific look at the video from the 70s
for the New York City [__] celty
[__] filthy the city so somebody's
smoking pot I'll never forget in 93 I
was working on 57th and 11 selling cars
like I was on 55th Let's Pretend 57th is
the big street you gotta walk up and I
would walk up and it was for Letterman
tapes and you know me guys before I left
[__] work I go to the bathroom roll a
number so once I hit [__] 57th I'd
start smoking and I would smoke past
people and their faces would drop like
that whole genre had disappeared from
New York people just didn't take a join
out like the [__] mid 80s that's when
Giuliani got a hold of yeah I would
smoke up 57th Street and people would
look at me walk up the hill like what
the [__] is he doing and it still didn't
stop me from smoking I'm one of these
people in my mind it's been illegal
everywhere since [__] when I was a
kid it's acceptable dog if you come over
here to say some the [__] people
across the street from me about three
months ago made the biggest mistake
they made the biggest mistake the goofy
lady with the blue and the boyfriend
that always wears the [__] Sinatra
hat yeah that half a [__] Momo she
came up to him there and she goes do you
always need to smoke on your balcony we
could smell it
and I just basically looked on it like
said like [__] you and kept walking with
my luggage it was on a Sunday after I
got off a six-hour flight you gonna come
over here and be cute I'm taking the
luggage out of the car and I can feel
her and her boyfriend walking over they
live across the street from me
you know I always smoke on my [__]
balcony what do you want me to go smoke
it's my [__] battle I pay rent up
there this little dumb [__] asked me
why must you smoke up there why why
would you like for me to smoke you
[__] [__] so wait not like you're
next door you mean like across the
street she's across the street though
they sit outside drinking beer all night
those two [__] idiots
and friends come up with have add-ons
they have hats too when they wear
sandals [__] through and they think
they're doing like a Michelob commercial
from the 80s they're out there and
they're all uglier than that both of the
broads are ugly both of the dudes are
[__] ugly I don't I wouldn't invite
them to nothing those four [__]
people there's nothing would I invite
them over there
she's bail as [__]
she's pale as [__] with these [__]
shorts you got a flat ass she's got a
hairdo from the [__] Go-Go's from the
80s and she's gonna come tell me not to
smoke [__] refried my balcony get the
[__] out of you and your boyfriend with
your [__] college shirt this [__] in
my life you should get like a fan and
just blow it towards her
I just keep listening to people next to
me they come out at six there's a lady
who looks like her husband beats her she
walks out of there every morning
she walks out there at six with another
French poodle Alyssa the husband kicks
four times at night too they walk past
me every morning and every morning they
look at me and I got that pipe in my
hand
it's about 6 15 and you have to see the
look on her [__] face
then I have two old ladies we have a
German Shepherd that I'm smoking I gotta
put the pipe away because the German
Shepherd likes me so I gotta stop what
I'm doing and go over and talk like a
German Shepherd wreaking of marijuana
reeking of marijuana and what else is
there
and somebody else who always sees me out
there puffing the black lady next door
she just don't even react to me no more
I know it destroys her but I'm not that
[__] smoker for some people black
people got annoyed me you smoke pot
around them we have the two black ladies
over here who get annoyed we got two the
black lady who threw us out of the
office over on Burbank Boulevard that
black woman I don't know what the [__]
up with black people know more now then
but I don't like it at all
yeah in my mind it's always been [__]
legal you know what I'm saying I'm one
of those [__] old school New Yorkers
listen if I'm over here stabbing a
[__] you got all the right in
the world to stop you know what I'm
saying oh thank you if I'm over here
smoking weed keep [__] driving look
at it's just two fat [__] smoking weed
talking about their high school days
that's it we ain't heard nobody
it's true but I got scared like I I
tried to walk with a joint once and I
just saw a cop car and I just threw the
joint away [__] no you could smoke right
next I don't know those morons don't
even know you can spark right next to
they'll start looking around
oh I'm like no no no no I thought I was
gonna get arrested nah they won't arrest
so how do you just do it you're coupled
in your hand and you keep walking
you look around like for a fake address
and wait for the light to change perfect
you gotta watch the [__] light
remember the the the Jersey yellow last
one it's how long is a light how long is
the thing I forget I don't know
do you know
I used to know and I was you know
you know I used to know the timings and
[__] if it's a stop sign you just cut
the joint your hand
and the smoke will go the other [__]
way I've done it a thousand times in
front of cops
but if this stop to the light you got a
few minutes to hold that joint and
eventually they're gonna see your
[__] smoke and put the [__] light
on you yeah that's what I didn't want
they were at a light but look they
didn't see me like I was behind them in
a parking lot
and I just got too scared I got arrested
for smoking reefer
1981. no no I got arrested for smoking
we thought in January of 1982 and I
thought my world was over with guys
that was one of the most scariest arrest
I was ever
involved
for the first time while I was laying on
the floor getting handcuffed
I actually thought about
what are they arresting me for for reals
like is this a robbery I did
that's how bad it was
and it was all over a [__] 75 bag of
weed
because they were looking for people
selling drugs to kids it was about vegan
and I never went to this weed place
I knew I knew it existed and I knew it
had good weed but I always stayed close
to the bridge I didn't want to lurk
around the city so I would get off the
bridge 178th Street and I would always
go to the nearest stores around there
for some reason that damn like what the
[__] I had the winning team in the Super
Bowl I picked up 800 I'm 19. let me walk
around the [__] City with 800 go eat
and I walked all the way to this place
because they had good chocolate Thai
wheat it was like two in the afternoon
that was the other [__] up I did
when were you supposed to do it
maybe a one maybe at lunch time when
there's more traffic on those streets
if you're not gonna come over at night
and hide and mix with the other cars
unless they look when they see three
white kids with Jersey plates you're
getting bulldog
really you're getting pulled over this
is 30 [__] years ago this is 35 years
ago
you see three [__] white kids on 178
in Amsterdam in a [__] car like a
nice car you're getting pulled over is
that like Harlem they're gonna ask you
how are you what are you doing this part
of town I'm here to visit Miami really
where she live
what Puerto Rican housing
around here this Mrs syad [__] live
at
take yourself and your drugs and get the
[__] sometimes they just and all listen
95 of the time they let you go guys you
know what they said to me they said
there's only two things white people do
around here buy drugs and get assaulted
and you look like you're up to both of
those
Jackson Heights did they let you go no
let us go yeah they stripped us down
this is in the 90s they stripped us down
and really right down the sidewalk yeah
four of us I was about 16 years old
they didn't care about the license now
in 94 it was a little tighter in 94 they
were already what they would do is if
you came over with your car from the uh
George Washington Bridge and if you
copped right there
on the way back they would clock your
your plate
didn't matter if you went on the lower
deck or the upper [__] deck they
would tell you go on the lower deck it
didn't [__] matter
and brother by the time you hit the
Jersey side there'd be a cop there
waving you in
and if they waved you in done
because if they searched that car the
car gets confiscated
it's interesting [__] you're done
yeah Don Lee cyan they would [__] go
to the engine they would ask you why the
[__] did you go over there for 10
minutes
they let you get away with you dropped
your girlfriend off one time
drop my girlfriend off what the [__] is
wrong with you she's Spanish I can't
date a [__] Spanish girl she works at
the med center check her out her name is
Debbie whatever the [__] and they would
look at you and they go all right get
the [__] out of here they had dogs duck
they had dogs
so you could drop 80 [__] names so
why wouldn't you just go around I said
then you start going to a Lincoln Tunnel
and getting stopping and getting the hot
dog clocking at least you have an excuse
me
not really
yeah you stand on the West Side Highway
and you shoot down and you go you have a
favorite hot dog place that's the only
place you shoot up like 58 57 got those
little [__] dudes and Greeks and they
sell the [__] Gyros on the street you
go over there by that time you're
already tuned up you rolled one up and
you smoked it you get yourself a [__]
slice of pizza a can of soda and you get
back on the Lincoln Tunnel like you
didn't do nothing nothing by that time
they don't even know they did you're off
the [__] radar
I used to walk over
never got stopped
never gonna [__] stop walking home
if for whatever reason
you had to go back then like there were
no dispensers anymore would it be tough
for you or could you get right back into
it we will get way come on
listen there's a bunch of people who
don't want to go to dispensaries right
now
there's still people who get insurance
benefits and medical benefits or veteran
benefits that said listen man I'm not
putting my name on that [__] list
and there's still a market for it people
are just going to go to the weed store
and sell it that's it
that's it people still gonna sell
[__] weed yeah listen what's going on
in Colorado you know how many times I've
been in [__] Philadelphia and
somebody's giving me a star or a gummy
bear or one of these [__] things or
cushy bad you know many [__] times
every [__] time I'm somewhere
somebody gives me something from me to
Colorado or California
Texas next week in Austin when you were
in Austin how many Cuba shoes did they
give you oh yeah yeah when you're in
Texas they're all over cheap yeah the
cheaper choose all over [__] Texas
so that's that's the biggest business
right now you know it's me you and him
you're the first week I'm the second
week and we're the third week the fourth
week we're like Jews we take Saturdays
off so the fourth week we're done nobody
makes a move so the fourth week you
drive from New Mexico with your [__]
Colorado Buffalo gear on and skis you
know what I'm saying I mean you got to
make it look right you could take three
pounds out of there and 10 million in
[__] little [__] cheaper juice
and pack on five dollars to each cheap
at you listen if I didn't have this
going on what do you think I'd be doing
all my boys in New York I have four of
them with menus and I email the menu a
week before and say place your orders
like then when you're in school and you
got cookies sent them to school same
thing you got to place your order and
give us a deposit
you understand me I get off the plane I
open the suitcase I give it to you you
give me my [__] cash I close it and I
get right back on the two o'clock plane
to Los Angeles people do it every
[__] day
and nobody would [__] know you think
they're flying they're not driving no
either that or they're sending it
they're just sending
I would I'd send it and send you with a
suitcase every [__] Tuesday you see
Louie on 155th Street and have eight
[__] meals going you understand me me
you my wife the baby everybody
everybody'd be [__] muelling right
now this would be you're crazy
with legit California we legit I take a
picture of the dispenser I'll get the
dispensary I get the especially to
certify that [__] so when I
shoot at your house I got the [__]
certification like a like a Babe Ruth
baseball card you understand me
oh we're making big lutely we're like
[__] blunt we're like [__] Johnny
Depp and blow like George Young whatever
his [__] name is let me get some
shout outs and he was just down in San
Diego oh George Young doing what doing a
speech at a convention last night
[__] crazy first off I want to give a
shout out to room 407 for the cigar he
put He carved out the [__] cigar and
put a joint in the cigar
put it in you know those metal
containers for cigar with the lid and
then the lid he popped out the [__]
Cork and put through its ass in there
you see I'm saying there's still good
solid Americans left whoever you are I
love you [__] and I owe you one
send me an email to the Church podcast
so I can send you a special present my
man Stephen Watkins Miguel Rizzo from
150 [__] FIB Street Chad Riza Peter
Garcia always looking good with the
glasses on my man who I'm going to see
in New York City next month the original
[__] Puerto Rican biker Renee and
Carson Michael gabard James sickler and
my man Jason Temple now one thing I tell
you [__] all the time I tell
people this constantly I don't give a
[__] how big the envelope is you never
ever ever ever ever fly on a Monday
you see what happened to it
can you imagine having the suitcase
filled with cheaper shoes
stuck at a [__] Airport dog sniffing
there you are all cheaper chewed the
[__] up
that's why I'm always nervous for you
when you take Edibles before you get to
the airport like what happens if you get
like stuck at like a 20 like a 27 hour
delay you're just kind of dog I found a
dead star in my luggage last week that
was harder than I told you you couldn't
buy fine [__] in my luggage every
[__] time
I'm prepared for war
do you understand me I'm prepared for a
walk you think I'm [__] kidding you
when I leave the house I put a couple
stars in me number two this there's
always some edible in the bag in the
emergency exit situation that means if
I'm stuck for up to 10 hours I'm good to
go number two there's always a joint
roll so when I get off the [__] plane
when I get to the car the joint is ready
to go with the lighter Scotch tape
somewhere around me
can't tell you where okay I'm always
ready there's no way I'm making it from
the airport to the house without smoking
a joint on the 405. that's just how I
roll that's just who Uncle Joey is
playing it [__] simple you starched
David somewhere you know me Doug I'm
like a Cuban James Bond I don't [__]
around with the lighter so there's no
drama because I don't want to leave the
lighter in the luggage then gotta open
my [__] I want to get in the car start
it up while the car is warming up I take
it out of where it's hidden I run up I
pay for [__] leave the airport and
once I hit that 405 [__] that joints
gets hit I'm cutting people off on the
HOV lane smoking a joint going uphill on
a [__] Sunday on the 405. you want to
ask yourself who's better than Uncle
Joey ask yourself [__]
you always got to be prepared to be
stuck at the airport I got a vapor pen
on me always got a tube and a backup
with both pens charged you understand me
ready to go I'm old school I got one of
these for the backup and I got the
button to work in Old School like a
[__]
bam I got three Valiums on me I got a
stick I got everything I got them hidden
in [__] iTunes speakers you know me
dog I'm [__] James Bond but I got
prescriptions
so if you stop me for those pills I got
a prescription for those anxiety pills I
just never take them because I don't
need them but if you're stuck in an
airport for 10 hours you're gonna need
them with a shot of vodka you get [__]
up Jack [__] up if you tell me listen
Joey you're stuck here for 12 hours I
might as well go to the bar eat a nice
[__] steak get the best steak they
got that [__] while I'm there
and then bound them like Bert crashing
go to the Admiral club and start telling
stories about Jews in heaven and all
that [__] and cracked [__] Doug
let me tell you something Colorado in
the old days
I used to leave I would leave
Aspen this is how [__] [__] I
look guys this is I'm talking about my
1980 [__]
six
I would take off from Aspen Airways like
seven which would get me into Denver by
eight which would put me on a United
flight
that would leave at nine o'clock
and would get me to [__] Jersey by
two o'clock
my friends would pick me up I go to West
New York make the drop off make the
pickup go right back and I take the five
o'clock out of the [__] whatever
which would get me to Aspen to to Denver
by eight but they used to be a nine
o'clock flight to ask but and you knew
when you landed if you were missing that
flight because it was the last flight
the [__] ask me and I'd have eight
ounces of blow on me
so I check them in those lockers because
I'd have it on my body like a [__] you
know me dog I'm all in I'm all in if
you're gonna if you're gonna get me
you're gonna get me
you know on the way that I would bring
pieces and on the way back I would bring
up the [__] block and I would get the
blow below wholesale back then I would
sell it [__] above retail back there
because they weren't getting that [__]
they weren't getting what we were
getting in the east coast those days
[__] no we were getting that [__]
chagavara [__] you know what I'm saying
we would get that heavy duty Cuban [__]
so I was bringing up that and I would
get stuck at the airport all night
John out of my [__] mind
all night I would spend eighty dollars
in court is getting the coke out of the
locker because it's a dollar to get the
key out I would put it in there and take
a rock out and go to the bar
and then get lit up and then [__] try
to get beers from somebody and then you
would sit there once the bars closer too
you would say that those six just
drinking water join by yourself I put
another dollar in the lock I take
another Coke rock out and sit there go
in the bathroom try to jerk off I was a
[__] messenger
did I get on the [__] plane all
whacked up oh my God
one time I did everything but raped by
Daddy
what stop
ped the police
no I would never she was some chick that
was hot and she told me she wanted to do
a blast and that's all I needed another
day when I was 21 22 if you took a blast
from me he was sucking my dick whether
you knew it or not I was doing something
I was and I started we started making
out in the plane I mean I tried to [__]
her in the in the third row like an
animal you know when you're from Jersey
you're an animal you don't give a [__]
where your dick comes out under a
blanket at least yeah no I put the
blanket over both of us I was trying to
touch him [__] but didn't work out my
arms weren't long enough it was a person
in between us
some always I kept waking her up
[Laughter]
it was crazy I used to Lee how I didn't
get arrested at those airports
how I did not get arrested at that one
time
two times one time
I had a jacket like Don Johnson
and in those days there was no metal
detector there was just a guy he took my
jacket and searched it
he searched the inside and he searched
these two pockets
The Weave was in the outside pocket
instead of having a flower had a joint
sticking up like Louis Lamour he
actually looked at it
and he goes what's this and I go
whatever you want it to be I'm in a rush
officer and he goes get the [__] out of
here he had no idea in my stomach I had
12 ounces of Coke
can you imagine they hit me for that
joint
then another time I was way gone already
the cops knew what I was doing
they knew exactly what was going on I
was just a [__] [__] here from
getting caught the Mets won the World
Series when the Mets win the World
Series anybody know 86 86 there you go I
flew back that weekend
and I get to my friend's house and the
water
the water broke in this house
the pipe bro this is the Savages they
were they never called a plum they
started snowing Coke downstairs and I
had to turn all the lights off they were
walking around with candles because you
electrocuted yourself you put a [__]
light on they started Coke for two days
in there with their pants rolled up like
fisherman
we would just pee whatever you know what
I'm saying
we would just be whatever I was trying
to [__] his sister it was horrible I
kept telling you got to drive me to the
airport yeah yeah the next one is like I
can't drive it to him it was like a two
thousand dollar cab ride to Canada
airport I get to Kennedy Airport it's
before the tunnels you got to walk
outside so they would point it to the
plan you had to actually walk outside
I'll never forget it was seven in the
morning it was freezing out
people had jackets on I walked out there
with a T-shirt and steam was coming over
the [__] body like a doctor
[Laughter]
I'm very lucky gentlemen to all be in
the room we all have a story or two how
you doing over there Captain you rolled
the blunt
what is that over there what'd you bring
some Colorado blend
okay
[__] look at them he's high as [__]
look at that little vapor pen and stuff
so what's the vision you guys see for
the future
what's the vision it's just uh keep on
expanding and educating people with
their uh with their ingestion you know
with this glycol with a uh glycerin and
coconut oil and that's not that shit's
not meant to be smoked it's not you know
so just uh and uh keep on you know we
got some good testimonials from from
real patients you know it's not it's uh
some good stuff when you when you see go
out there and see it and uh and you put
your hands on it you really see what's
going on with uh with the ailments and
stuff and uh coming out with a big CBD
line you know and uh some of the
ailments do you know you need the THC as
a conduit for the CBD you know very
little bit but you do and uh does it get
you high the CBD yes with the THC in it
no well yeah it depends on what the
blend is you know if you do a 50 50 or
you know it's it depends on what
elements what's the least
THC you should have in the CBD like five
percent
yeah and not get high but still get the
full benefit yes yes for the most part
and the CBDs that you know helped me
with pain and the and the sleep as well
you know and some uh edible companies
we're talking with that uh that there's
a lot of a lot of r d being being done
right now but when the for when uh the
rules uh roll out in the next year and a
half
in the next year and a half now let me
ask you something
I had a gentleman in here a couple
months ago a great guy he's working with
a guy trying to help him out he's got a
CBD line
great stuff honey cbdo 51 you know no
THC you know and I heard the same
argument that it only gets activated
with a little bit of THC now that do you
have to smoke it or at the same time or
could I do a CBD and smoke reefer and
get the same effect from the CBD
what what some of the animals like the
epilepsy for the for the kids right
um You don't need the THC there's an
argument out there that the THC helps it
a little bit more you know
um above my pay grade Joe you know to be
honest with you I don't know but I know
that there is other things that people
say in testimonials that the THC it does
help
um like I said a conduit activates the
CBD faster quicker you know this is
gentleman that I'm working with the CBD
Global extracts this guy uh um he really
he really knows what he's doing and
um he's uh he's planning uh now he's
working with doctors and stuff he's
doing another level from just trying to
just get in people's hands
it's a unique guy doesn't he doesn't
even like you know there's an Avenue I
showed him and it was more about the
money and he's like no I don't need that
you know he he really cured his father's
cancer that's he was a he was a tech guy
his father got cancer and he cured it he
singly single-handedly cured it with the
with uh the CBDs and the THC and then he
just kept on Snowball Effect and he's
out there making some major waves as far
as I'm concerned one one of the more
serious people that I've met doing it
and um I'd love for him to call in and
get and talk to you you know he's uh
you know the amount of information he's
got yeah I love I really love to get to
the bottom of this because I think it's
the future yeah I think CB and everybody
I mean when he came on I had maybe 75
people who sent me emails that they're
really interested in this because now
they're saying it's legal in 50 states
you can ship this stuff but you can't
ship it if it has the THC and you could
ship it without maybe that's why I'm
thinking maybe you could drop it
but I read some of the people who did
buy it from the show and I read his page
and that testimonial is not a pretty
[__] impressed yeah yeah you know
like I said I roll around a jiu jitsu
I'm 50 [__] three
come home I make a protein shake I eat
lunch and I hit that [__] in the morning
and at night I sleep a little better I
sleep a little bit more solid now I have
my ups and downs with sleep but that's
because I [__] need nicotine gum and
I'll drink a Yoo-hoo at midnight which
will [__] keep you up till six the
[__] morning it's like 19 espressos
and [__] like that how can people find
out about your products
then go on our website Eureka vapor.com
or in uh numerous collectives up and
down the coast of California and
Colorado as well we're up I think we're
in about 30 plus stores right now we're
making a um natural remedies which is
right off the 16th Street Mall uh dank
which they These Guys these guys run
unbelievable business both of those
gentlemen and um
there's uh you know strain wise like
this if you go on the website it's got a
list of where where you can locate us
you know for uh you know California it's
Medical Only Colorado there's
recreational and Med really yeah so it's
the lowest rate this is all I gotta say
and this is all I gotta [__] say
about this that as you know we had a
thousand milligrams to another Stars
we don't [__] around here
we did maybe [__] we did maybe five
bomb hits a piece you know our tolerance
is high you know we get he's embarrassed
he calls me some nice things like I hate
600 milligrams and not napping Joey this
is [__] up and we're like we got a way
off you know we can't go every [__]
night you know I leave him on Thursday
he doesn't do nothing Thursday on Friday
say he hooks up with the girlfriend
and he eats these things then we go deep
on [__] Monday and Wednesday I don't
even know why didn't we didn't do his
acid tonight we just we just I'm giving
him some training time till September we
go deep every night every [__] night
together someone asked me last night so
when was the last time you took like a
tolerance break and I was like
never there's no tolerance brace here we
don't we don't play that vacation time
but I gotta honestly tell you man
my man he has showed up one night
and when that came over here I forgot
that I left him here
and I came over here like five days
later with my daughter and my wife
and my wife and I go oh [__]
and I [__] took these out and I took
a
a couple pens out and I took some of the
cartridges out
and I went home and that night I said
you know what when I pack them I'll fly
I mean I can't believe how many times I
fly and it's in the front flap and it
goes right through the machine they give
me the [__] bag I go I can't [__]
believe these people
but uh
like I say guys I smoke in hotel rooms
and I get baked off it baked
baked I gotta take six or seven hits but
I get [__] baked you know what I'm
saying like I go I gotta take a shower
you know when I'm on an airport I'll
[__] smoke those things you get so
bad I don't smoke on a plane no more I
got caught on the plane that's it
that's it I didn't think the [__] uh
bathroom could get it the [__]
bathroom went off it's buzzing she's
banging on the door I open the doors and
she's like I don't smell no cigarettes
like what I'm telling you I don't know
what happened I banged some
she goes this is the second time this
happened this week
no no so I thought they were gonna pull
me over in LAX
so I took the tube and put it in my
luggage head and the sleep apnea machine
sit in the back we have something to
hear who wants to speak to him like God
damn it
so
That's it man dog I'm finally got I'm
happy we came on yeah so what's the
website again Eureka vapor
e-u-r-e-k-a-v-a-p-o-r.com and this is to
retailers only no this is for for the
consumer to find out where where we uh
where the product could be found
in Colorado and California okay so if I
want if I live in San Diego yes and I'm
gonna get some uh Eureka Vape I go to
this webpage they'll tell me what store
it's at blah blah blah blah you have
stores up here where is it in the valley
in the valley where are we at
it's go on the website there's there's
numerous I don't want to single out one
guy you know because you know no
favoritism no hey you gotta be fair no I
just was curious where I saw it because
I only go to three stores so obviously
the sunset perennial
well the other one rose
yeah it was one of those three who gave
me that pen
yeah so and they're doing great with it
so you know God bless them no I always
bro we started talking about five
[__] years ago yeah five [__]
years ago I still have the original it's
still 10 you gave me two of them one
something happened that just went a
little smoke came out those are the
early days
there was a lot of but the other one is
still alive and Tekken yeah I just gotta
charge it up if I don't charge it up it
dies so I gotta charge it up it's still
alive in Texas
it's been uh it's come a long way that's
for sure you know and we in uh Eureka
vapor and open we're the first real CO2
extractors in the country open you know
was the the first guys they're the big
boys and uh in ourselves you know
there's other guys out there that are
starting to make oil now you know they
were buying five liters when people were
buying you know
a lot bigger than five liters you know
times by a hundred and uh and it's uh
but everybody's involved you know the
information's out there now you can go
on YouTube and figure out how to do it
back then there was nothing
CO2 was a myth we're down there I was
down there banging on doors like a
[__] Bible sales man people looking
at me like
it just was horrible it was it was it
was it was a tough road but
they definitely thought I was selling
freaking snake oil so as you know
the kiss of death always follows us we
should have never got rid of Lee's
office we got rid of leaves off this has
been nothing but downhill we almost lit
that off the signified
that everywhere we go in this [__]
drama so we went to the one place we got
kicked out then we went to the other
place
and they [__] barely kicked this out
but we had a weed delivery service next
to us yeah we were cool with that one
but we never sold they kept saying that
we couldn't smoke in there but they kept
saying we smell all this in there one
night some lady fell in the hallway you
know it was always [__] something
there's a homeless dude this dude that
he robbed the Mexican woman and [__] is
hysterical we have to kiss the death
when it comes to offices so I walked
past here when I see this place the
guy's like you still want it yeah after
two years I came here
we set it up boom we get in here I don't
even know if we got a complain
first we are bung disappear I left in
the bathroom you know I like to wash my
bangs and I listen to the bathroom
somebody clipped it we took this as a no
big deal I went in this who would throw
away a bomb who would throw away a bomb
you know what I'm saying like who's
[__] would throw away a bun these
[__] people throw away a [__] bunk
I go on that buy another [__] bong I
rinse it out I get high I take a piss I
forget I leave [__] Lee don't check
in there either the bomb gets taken I'm
down to zero two then we get a text one
day that says listen yeah what did it
say at least something about the weed oh
it's too strong oh yeah like I could
probably find it no no don't find it but
it says
we've got some complaints and we we
usually don't say anything but it is we
smell it and it's very strong
can you please stop so before we come in
here and we're smoking this white now
this white isn't just good weed this
white felt upside down in my draw like
that draw where you have Staples and
pennies and fingernail Cutters and [__]
and my foot file so it's filled with
dust so I just scraped it up and put it
all in this there's a staple in there
it's tremendous this weed will kill a
meal so me and Leah going in here bangko
bong with the door closed we do about
seven [__] buckets and all of a
sudden we opened the door up and I do
this
[__] coughing
I mean this guy coughed for 20. [__]
minutes
he even came out
and then we're here
and he kept coughing and coughing then
you heard him walking down
oh that's so we feel like we're pretty
much out of here like we're gonna get
the piece of paper any [__] data oh
oh yeah thank God I'm moving September
1st
thank God I got a new office right
behind my house
so we could just take this whole [__]
thing and reset it up and take it down
what a [__] nightmare
our life never ended this [__] trait
to what's happened now we just wrap it
up and doing the [__] coffee shop and
take away the video I told you that [__]
it never ends we got our bong stolen who
steals your [__] bunk
then they took a picture of the bomb and
sent it to us
and that's as if it was ours what does
it matter you know whose it is you just
complained about the [__] reefer now
you want to ask if it's [__] it just
never ends and they want the someone
texted me and said that they wanted to
check the cameras to see who it was
so they were like up in arms about it
they must talk about us all the time in
like the hallways they must be like I
hate those people like coming twice
every week you know it smells weird in
the office next day
because I'm blowing this Eureka vaping
perfect I can't wait to hear that
[__] coughing about 4.8 minutes
all you hear me saying God damn it these
[__] are smoking something good
and we can't blame for everything we do
no no every business every [__] place
we've been
there's always something we had a camera
at the other place
I'm telling you leave we're just gonna
do it from a coffee shop and forget the
visuals
you have to make sure there's no and
that's the weirdest thing because we
have like great black people who listen
to us and love us but there's something
about black women in offices near us
every time we have black people next to
us don't like us it's like having a
Chinese dude behind you when you play
Blackjack
you always go down in flames you know
what I'm saying you get thrown out you
got a Chinese guy chasing you in the car
it's a [__] nightmare anyway
as always on it.com is there for you I'm
stuck on the Hem [__] protein now the
last couple days they sent me some of
that cocoa every [__] day two scoops
a banana maybe no banana just ice cubes
and water I feel great it's a great
[__] product if it's not that
whenever I got the jet lag I'll take a
little Alpha Brain with two scoops of
the CBD oil again it goes away like a
[__] Soldier you know I'm a big
[__] on it guy I just got the mixed
greens again tremendous the shrimp Tech
and I'm a big believer listen they're
always getting new stuff they always got
sales do me a favor go to audit.com
right now
read about all the stuff they have read
about a product give it a shot I mean
they give you a 30 day uh Alpha brand is
100 money back if you don't like it who
does that in this [__] business go to
honda.com right now take a look at the
fine stuff they got if you like
something on the way out go to the box
and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h [__] and get you 10 off
and it gets delivered right to your
[__] house Gratis where are you gonna
get that type of action so go to on it
before the podcast is over number two
you know me dog I'm a [__] uh like I
was telling these dudes they put two
straws in my nose and I had that surgery
I had that surgery about a month ago
today four weeks ago today they cleaned
up my whatever and then they put two
straws and then they put stitches to
hold in the [__] straws
and the second night I'm sitting down
oxycontin's all [__] up I'm smoking
weed I'm eating some Stars
and I'm thinking to myself 10 years ago
I'd be looking for a [__] straw right
now right now I got two straws in my
[__] nose you know what I'm saying
can you imagine
if you could [__] get the patent for
that
to put like a Coke snorter who just
can't stop this is [__] I can't take
this no more instead of putting two
fangs like a vampire just put two straws
in his nose and he goes to a party at
night he's like who's doing blowing
people like I am I am me just cause I
just
and a straw pops out of his nose he does
a line he inhales the straw back and
then those and he walks out who's better
than you you know what I'm saying that's
the most interesting man in the world so
you always trying to be you know when
you could do that type of [__] you
imagine the type of savoir Fair
game that you have
what I'm getting to is we all try to be
[__] PA called Dan and we all try to
get wine and do this and do that and you
know as guys we try to be [__] we
create we fake the funk but we're no
good we're no good at one you have been
a why now at your local store and you're
staring at the selection of wine you
don't know what idea what bother chews
what goes with what you hope it's going
to be good well guess what the days of
playing Russian roulette with your wine
selections are over Jack Club W is a
revolutionary new wine club that takes
the guesswork out of choosing your wine
they have a simple six question palette
quiz that will match you with the
delicious high quality wine you're
guaranteed to love let me tell you
something the best part is Club W will
actually ship your wine straight to your
door no more going to the store and
being lost in the wine aisle and then
you don't know what the [__] you're
doing no no it gets delivered to your
door
Okay and like I said to you it's a great
system you go to the web page you go to
Club W you take the little testy pool
and they'll tell you what wine works
with what they even tell you what you
could eat with it I mean that's how much
they're into this club W you have the
freedom to pick then choose the type of
wine the number of bottles you receive
each month okay they cut out the
middlemen they deal directly with The
Vineyards you follow me so start
drinking personalized wine selections
today plus they offer a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed on every single
bottle do me a favor right now Club W is
offering twenty dollars off your first
order when you go to
dubclubw.com
Joey again twenty dollars off your first
order when you go to clubw.com
Joey and guess what it gets better I
know you all hate paying for shipping
bam Club W will actually pay for the
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more so take something off the to-do
list just go to Club
w.com slash Joey to get twenty dollars
off your first order today right now
that's
clubw.com Joey How You Like Me Now [__]
it's 1998 and I got to pick whatever the
[__] with a chicken and the court don't
burn the [__] candle Lisa yet always
I'm gonna tell you what the best thing
is
right now is the time of the year
concerts are heating up the Constitution
ending up Black Sabbath it's about to
close off that tour I know Peter Gabriel
and the other guy what's his name sting
is about to close off that door and I'll
tell you what buying tickets online for
sports and cons since has been a
confusing process for a long time it's
always been hard to find the best deal
for the game or show you want to go to
and none of those older ticket sites
want to charge that want to change that
but seek geek is different they've come
a long way and they've created an
amazing app and a website that makes it
easier than ever for fans to buy and
sell tickets okay SeatGeek is always the
first place I go in and look for tickets
to a game or a concert I know Josh Wolf
had to go to a Boston Red Sox game this
week he called me and I told him go to
SeatGeek and he got great tickets he
said I have a seat geek app on my phone
and I just use it the other day like I
said with Josh Wolf just to find the Red
Sox game seek geek does all the price
comparison for you by searching multiple
ticket sites and ensuring that you get
the best possible deal seek geek does
all the work and you save time and money
and seek Geeks wants you to help you get
the most bang for your buck that's why
every ticket on seek geek is given a
grade based on the value you immediately
see the unpriced seats and be able to
find the best deals that fit your budget
best of all my listeners the church gets
twenty dollars off rebate on their first
seat geek purchase so do me a favor
right now to get your 20 rebate download
seek geek at right now
s-e-a-t capital g e e k app go to the
settings and tab and click add promo
code again go to settings and tab and
click add promo code enter the promo
Club Church
c-h-u-r-c-h seek equals send you 20
hours after you've made your first
ticket purchase it's that simple
download the seat geek app and enter the
promo code Church
c-h-u-r-c-h you're going to the Sabbath
concert the Hollywood Bowl this is your
chance to order the seek geek app okay
so do me a favor get your twenty dollars
go to SeatGeek app and press in church
today I want to thank Club W I want to
thank seed geek I want to thank God I
want to thank my boys for [__] Eureka
for coming down explaining this uh whole
game that's getting confusing because
it's getting confusing for people it's
you know you walk into a a medium level
Medical Marijuana store now and there's
20 [__] Vapors and they don't know
really what they're selling you know
what I'm saying they're selling whatever
they [__] tell them to sell it's very
knowledgeable you know a lot of people
aren't that knowledgeable
they'll tell you what's the most popular
you know what I'm saying so but I'm
happy you came down to break it down for
these [__] I am happy to be
here
thank you for coming Lee how you feeling
[__] liquor
I'm feeling really good good thousand
are you ready for two more hundred can
you handle it [__] yeah what the [__]
if you don't get an anxiety attack in
your sleep you ain't sleeping right you
know what I'm saying
there you go like the doctor and [__]
don't drop it
forget what one anybody you wanna see
the devil
devil I understand I ain't gonna force
you to see a little Diablo listen we'll
be back Wednesday I don't know what
[__] time we'll let you know on
Twitter we'll let you know again I want
to thank seek geek club W and on it I
want to thank Lee I want to thank my
boys from [__] Eureka and I'll see
you guys this weekend at the Denver
Comedy Works
or next Friday at the [__] Ice
House 8 15. it's the no uh
expectations tour that's what I'm going
to tell you [__] all right so I
either see you in Denver this weekend or
next weekend at the ice house as part of
the no expectations to him still working
things out so be there or be square
concept because thank you for listening
have a great night be safe see you
[__] Wednesday stay black
with you
foreign
thank you